hello and welcome to zeal playing D girl
with black yeah I keep getting comments
on the videos why I am playing lower
rated opponents almost exclusively it's
just like what happens here on only
chess it's not really my choice all that
much I'm just like in the top 99
something percent of players and there
are rarely people online that have a
higher rating than I have let alone that
they would play three plus two so I
wouldn't mind stronger opposition but
it's just not there and also um I'm not
really not like I win every game it's
just what it is it's not a one way
street
those games so um here white is getting
some nice initiative going under on the
kingside oh wait I just recognized if I
care so long there is Knight takes c6
would schwa that would be painful for
Boden's mate 96b takes Queen a6 mate
ouch
hmm that's not good hmm yeah what do I
play then I cannot cast long it's going
to be a bit ugly not happy not happy
if ii was more awaiting move than
anything else still not happy wow he
just takes it why why would you take it
that makes I didn't think that make much
sense so now he gives me that pawn weird
okay so it seems like he wants to put
some pressure on h6 but my bishop is
just reliably covering this so I'm going
for c5 now I'm just trying to open up
the bishop okay now yeah it would be
would be good to get h5 plate yeah
that's very slowly
[Music]
not certain if g5 is an idea and then
put the bishop over to like if it takes
it difficult the same I can do this here
double and then play age five it's very
strange
okay wants to put the Knight to e5 but
okay if I get aged five and I'm I'm kind
of okay
I forgot that he has 95 now actually
threatening 97 mate okay yeah here Queen
f5 a thought is good for the pin and
ultimately the caption on h5
yeah 95 was was a problem I thought yeah
now I've in very good shape I think it's
got the weak F pawn and my H pawn is is
dangerous you know he just has a check
there on d7 that's not so dangerous
queen g-form yeah but it's not not very
urgent just pushing this forward this is
good meanie he cannot move with an idea
okay
now I get to promote one yeah I can take
night F to what that position is just
completely lost and they win f4 yeah
there was a somewhat weird game so yeah
he played the Barry attack it is called
the solid line
what can definitely play like that I'm
not really an expert I just played like
normal looking moves but he definitely
has an advantage so probably when I
played wasn't that great yeah here I
noticed that I shouldn't care so long
because of this one a good mating
pattern - no Boden's mate so and it's
just completely a way I'm threatening
here and here and everything so I had to
do something else at age six was kind of
I don't know what did you move f3 that
looked okay and now I decided to take
some play not knowing anything else
and then finally castling long and now
we eat strangely took on f6 I don't know
why I'm why would you trade your good
piece there are only five like e4 yeah
anything really
this is Jack giving up on on any
advantage because now I have a five as
an immediate threat and this is hanging
so you don't have a good move there
Queen edge - given by the comp I still
have e5 so but should we have six is
really quite bad yeah the way it turned
out he just gave me that pawn which I
was happily taking and at that moment he
had spent no time at all but its
position is already bad
so yeah well I played c5 and the trade
yeah now I'm not sure I can definitely
do many things here that make sense that
are probably a bit better I mean with
this set up I'm always keeping age six
because there is no way for him to
maneuver the night in a way that it
would a check h6 so I can also do what
the engine suggests to play route d6
rook c8 and play on the Queen side that
is maybe more logical but okay I try to
get the H pawn on the way and that is
what what happened however I think you
should definitely not take on age five I
was thinking Knight c5 but okay the
engine just says okay more the king and
nothing happens you know it's kind of
it's true
the computer suggests f5 that is a
pretty drastic move there but it makes a
lot of sense and this one may now it's
not clear it's not clear oh yeah but
this I think is probably just using you
yeah I just take this and that you
simply cannot cannot stand it's too too
much of an advantage energy I'm
promoting you can only prevent the
immediate promotion with this but this
is of course just quite clearly winning
yeah okay guys thanks for watching